Hey guys, it's Joel with the Tabaret Therapy Collective podcast. And I haven't done like a big article, essay, podcast in a minute. We've done a lot of interviews and things. And I also get some feedback from people because I get really excited about an idea. I'm kind of obsessive. Like I get on a thing and then I try and like learn a ton about it. And then I want to talk to somebody else who's like really smart about that thing. And I try and line up guests that have, uh, you know, something to do with, uh, you know, something that I hope is relevant to you and psychotherapy
大家好，我是Tabaret Therapy Collective播客的Joel。我已经有一阵子没有写过长文章、随笔或录制播客了。我们之前做了很多采访和相关内容。我也收到了一些反馈，因为我对某个想法总是感到非常兴奋。我有点强迫症，一旦迷上某件事，就会试图去深入了解它。然后，我想找一个对这件事非常精通的人聊聊。我努力邀请那些与心理治疗、文化、政治等相关，且我认为对你们有意义的嘉宾，
and culture and politics and all that, but also, um, something that I'm obsessing over and, um, have been learning a lot about. And then when I get on the interview with the guests, a lot of the feedback that I've gotten, it's like, hey, shut up, you're interrupting the guest. And maybe one way that I can be better about having more of a conversation and not, you know, interrupting, you know, I'm interrupting too much. That's not a good thing, is to sit with some of these ideas. And in sitting with some of those ideas in an essay thing with just me, you know, you just got to listen to me, it's easier to go into an interview. So anyway, something I'm trying out. And recently, this has to do with the topic today.
同时也是我正在沉迷并深入学习的主题。但在采访嘉宾时，我收到的很多反馈是：“嘿，闭嘴，你打断嘉宾了。”也许我能做得更好，进行更多的对话而不是频繁打断，因为打断别人并不是好事。我可以静下心来思考这些想法，通过写随笔的方式独自梳理，这样在进行采访时会更容易。总之，这是我正在尝试的一种方式。最近，这与今天的主题有关。
I was reading Michael S. Judge's book, which is Lyrics of the Crossing. It's a really good novel. And the thing in the beginning of it, there's a section in the beginning that I think is relevant to what we're talking about today. So I'm going to read that. The watcher's eyes now give out light. The light's receiver flower, coiled up behind their nose bones, changes place. It crawls out through their pupils, the bundled nervy flowers making a circuit between each other. Bolts the color of limes Boil forking through the busy air Their brains are still inside them
我正在读Michael S. Judge的书《Lyrics of the Crossing》，这是一部非常好的小说。书的开头有一段内容，我认为与我们今天讨论的话题相关，所以我打算读一下。“观察者的眼睛现在发出光芒。光的接收花，蜷缩在他们的鼻骨后，改变了位置。它从瞳孔爬出，成束的神经花在彼此之间形成回路。石灰色的闪电在繁忙的空气中沸腾分叉，他们的大脑仍然在他们体内。”
But the sundown is made to simmer With a brain that none of them quite have alone And each one has something like it Facets of the brain's shelled diamond The cage-strumming man Str strings out his carousel of shapes, while catgut thrums out slippery chords, and the people watching him are in the circuit of an ancient battery that sleeps behind their eyes, and none of them will know how to tell what has happened,
“但日落被煮得沸腾，带着一种他们独自一人时并不完全具备的大脑。每个人都有类似的东西，大脑贝壳状钻石的切面。那个拨弄笼子的男人，弹奏着他的形状旋转木马，而猫肠弦发出滑溜的和弦，看着他的人们处于一个古老电池的回路中，那电池在他们眼中沉睡，没有人知道该如何描述发生了什么，”
but everyone will know that it can happen again. And they'll say, I was a tree. I was a vine that sucked the brass work. I was an ivy knot that lived on the milk of stones. So that's from Michael S. Judge's Lyrics of the Crossing, which I'm not very far into. And it's a description which has a whole lot going on, you know, probably talk about that for an hour. But also it's a description that is of a bard, you know, like a performer singing a song, doing some kind of performance. And in the section before that, he talks about the catgut cage because, you know, the strings of old tennis rackets the strings of old instruments were made with cat gut but he describes the lyre or whatever this guy is playing like it is a cage he calls it a cage stringed with cat gut but it's an instrument
“但每个人都知道它可能会再次发生。他们会说，我曾是一棵树。我曾是一根吸食黄铜制品的藤蔓。我曾是一个以石头之乳为生的常春藤结。”这段话出自Michael S. Judge的《Lyrics of the Crossing》，我还没读多少。这段描述包含了很多内容，可能谈论一个小时都谈不完。但它也是对吟游诗人——也就是表演者唱歌或进行某种表演的描述。在这一节之前，他提到了“猫肠笼”，因为旧网球拍和旧乐器的弦是用猫肠做的，但他把这个家伙弹奏的里拉琴或其他乐器描述为一个笼子，他称之为用猫肠弦系住的笼子，但它是一个乐器。
and if you think about um you know classical mythology who plays the lyre? It's Orpheus, right? And the lyre makes such beautiful music that he can call a soul out of the underworld, except for the one he wants. He has this beautiful lyre. But here, Judge is calling it a cage that is trapping something. And there's something going on there about the music basically pulling these people's brains outside of their eye holes because the sunset, like the setting that they're in, or the time that they're in maybe, we don't know if it's a sunset on a beach or the sunset that
如果你想想古典神话，谁弹奏里拉琴？是俄耳甫斯，对吧？里拉琴能奏出如此美妙的音乐，以至于他能把灵魂从冥界召唤出来，除了他想要的那一个。他有这把美丽的里拉琴。但在这里，Judge称它为一个正在困住某种东西的笼子。这里面有些名堂，音乐基本上把这些人的大脑从眼眶里拉了出来，因为日落，或者他们所处的环境，或者他们所处的时代——我们不知道这是海滩上的日落，还是他所描述的文化变革时代的日落——
he's describing of an epoch changing of culture, connects all of their brains, right? Like what a wild description. The lights receiver flower coiled up behind their nose bones. That's your brain. It's the receiver flower coiled up behind your nose bone that receives the light, right? The cage, the instrument, the culture, the music pulls these people's brains either because of the time that they're in or the place that they're in something about this setting and he calls the brain he says faucets of the brain shall dime and they're only like a piece of a whole thing when they're pulled out and connected that connection and there's a battery language there's a circuit language it's an electricity becomes something that is bigger than them and also alive, right? So it's this connection that makes something bigger than all of these people alive in a way that they're a part of it and they know it, but they also don't know it. And there's just
连接了他们所有的大脑，对吧？多么狂野的描述。“蜷缩在鼻骨后的光的接收花”。那就是你的大脑。它是蜷缩在鼻骨后接收光线的接收花，对吧？笼子、乐器、文化、音乐，把这些人的大脑拉了出来，要么是因为他们所处的时代，要么是因为他们所处的地点，这种环境有些特别。他称大脑为“大脑贝壳状钻石的切面”，当它们被拉出并连接时，它们只是整体的一部分。那种连接，以及电池的语言、回路的语言，这是一种电，变成了一种比他们自身更大且有生命的东西，对吧？所以，这种连接使某种比所有这些人加起来更大的东西以一种他们参与其中且知晓，但又并不完全知晓的方式活着。这里面有
so much there. Um, and I, I, if that doesn't make sense, that's fine. I think a lot of those themes are going to be relevant to what we're getting into. You know, the sundown has made the sundowns made to simmer with a brain that none of them quite have alone. You know, we are building a circuit by connecting people with a culture that is also a cage. And it is making them something that is not them by connecting them, right? And this is, this book is like 900 pages. Like, I don't know how I'm ever going to read it. This is on page 14, okay? The whole novel is written like this.
太多的东西了。如果这听起来没道理，没关系。我认为很多主题都与我们要讨论的内容相关。“日落被煮得沸腾，带着一种他们独自一人时并不完全具备的大脑。”我们正在通过将人们与一种同样是笼子的文化连接起来来构建一个回路。它通过连接他们，使他们变成了某种不是他们自己的东西，对吧？这本书有900页，我不知道我该怎么读完它。这只是第14页，好吗？整部小说都是这样写的。
It's not a book of poetry. I can't really tell you. I mean, I would already recommend it, but I can't really say much more about how to recommend it to you because I haven't gotten beyond, you know, I think I'm on page 50 or something of this giant book. So I'm going to get into what I'm talking about today, which is the era that we're in is characterized by this hyper-rationality that if you can't see it, taste it, touch it, it's not real. And a lot of that comes from science and this pursuit of objective truth, production, accomplishment, consumption. And the human psyche that you see culturally, it finds itself just adrift in all of these pieces of culture and images that aren't really functioning like
这不是一本诗集。我真的说不好。我的意思是，我已经会推荐它了，但我无法多说该如何向你们推荐，因为我还没读到那儿，我想我大概读到第50页左右。所以我要进入今天的主题，那就是我们所处的时代特征是这种超理性主义：如果你看不见、尝不出、摸不着，它就不是真实的。这很大程度上源于科学以及对客观真理、生产、成就和消费的追求。你在文化中看到的人类心理，发现自己只是漂浮在所有这些文化碎片和图像中，它们并没有像
culture and image used to mean. I mean, they're disconnected from these previous myths that used to give us purpose. Like they're the same symbol that's reminding them of something, but it's something that we don't quite believe anymore. And there's a lot of things that are traditional or hierarchical that seem hollow or erroneous. I see that coming up all the time in therapy now. And I see patients every day that describe this phenomenon, and they don't use those words, but it's as if they are saying, I don't know who I am anymore, but I don't know who i am anymore but i don't know who i am anymore not because i changed because all these nodes and reference points that i used to have in a culture to contextualize my identity have been stripped away and they've been made foreign
文化和图像过去那样发挥作用。我的意思是，它们与那些曾经赋予我们目的的神话脱节了。它们是同一个符号，提醒着人们某种东西，但那是一种我们不再完全相信的东西。有很多传统的或等级制度的东西看起来空洞或错误。我现在在治疗中经常看到这种情况。我每天都见到描述这种现象的病人，他们虽然不用这些词，但他们仿佛在说：“我不知道我是谁了，我不知道我是谁了，我不知道我是谁了。”不是因为我变了，而是因为我在文化中用来构建身份的所有节点和参考点都被剥离了，它们变得陌生，
and they've been incomprehensible i can't grab onto it anymore. But the world looks the same. I remember it. It didn't change, but it looks the same, despite the fact that it is making me feel alienated and terrified and upset. And so it's not the aesthetics of the world that are different. The aesthetics are the same, but the effect that it has on me is different. But I can't see that. I can only feel that. So what the hell is it? Why? I must be crazy, right? Because I'm looking at a world that looks the same, but none of these symbolic images are working in the way that they're supposed to work. And so because the world looks the same, we feel crazy. When really it's our feelings that are telling us that the world is crazy,
变得不可理解，我再也抓不住它们了。但世界看起来还是一样。我记得它。它没有变，但它看起来一样，尽管它让我感到疏离、恐惧和不安。所以，世界的审美并没有改变。审美是一样的，但它对我的影响不同了。但我看不见这一点。我只能感觉到。那到底是什么？为什么？我一定是疯了，对吧？因为我看着一个看起来一样的世界，但所有这些象征性的图像都没有按照它们应该有的方式运作。因为世界看起来一样，我们觉得自己疯了。而实际上，是我们的感觉在告诉我们这个世界疯了，
even though it looks the same. And, you know, like, what do we do as therapists or patients just looking to find a therapist that kind of gets this somewhat? You know, effective therapy in this modern world, it needs to go over, it needs to get over its insecurities of the therapist feeling or looking crazy, okay? You know, if we don't let ourselves as therapists admit to patients that we also feel this pain and that we also feel crazy from these same forces, then how can, if you can't acknowledge these, then how can therapy,
尽管它看起来一样。那么，作为治疗师或寻找治疗师的病人，我们该怎么办？在这个现代世界中，有效的治疗需要克服治疗师感到或看起来疯狂的不安全感。如果我们作为治疗师不让自己向病人承认我们也感到这种痛苦，我们也因为这些相同的力量而感到疯狂，那么，如果你不能承认这些，治疗又怎么能，
or if you're not even aware of it as a therapist, because you are feeling it, then how can therapy do anything but gaslight us more? You know, we see the news, and like I see the news when I'm in a dentist's office or i have i've been recently have been sick like six times which is why i'm been gone for so long but like i feel when i look at the news like i'm on drugs even though i'm sober it's just like what is happening on tv like and i and i don't mean that I disagree with what's happening. I mean, I largely do. I mean, like, it doesn't seem real. Okay. It's a bigger issue than I don't like it. It's that it
或者如果你作为治疗师甚至没有意识到这一点，因为你正在感受它，那么治疗除了进一步对我们进行煤气灯操纵（精神控制）还能做什么呢？我们看新闻，比如我在牙医诊所看新闻，或者我最近生病了六次，这就是我离开这么久的原因，但当我看着新闻时，我感觉自己像是在吸毒，尽管我清醒。电视上发生的事情就像……我并不是说我不同意正在发生的事情。我的意思是，我大部分都不同意。我的意思是，它看起来不真实。这是一个比“我不喜欢它”更大的问题。问题在于它
makes me feel like I don't understand what's happening. Like this is, it's surreal. And, you know, I know that the people on the TV don't believe what they're saying and they're kind of, but they, even they look like they're going through the motions of something that isn't real anymore you know all angles of this you know and i'm not a politician i'm not a god i'm a therapist and so i'm paralyzed against these forces too you know as my patients are i can't do anything about them all i can do is reckon with them and in reckoning with them um you know like i can tell the patient i don't know how to do that you know i don't know how to reckon with these things but they are real what you are feeling looks true you know i'm turning on the news and people are trying to get me to fight about these
让我觉得我不明白正在发生什么。这太超现实了。我知道电视上的人并不相信他们所说的话，他们有点……但即使是他们，看起来也像是在走过场，做着一些不再真实的事情。你知道，这方面的所有角度。我不是政治家，我不是神，我是一名治疗师，所以我对这些力量也感到瘫痪，就像我的病人一样。我对此无能为力，我所能做的就是面对它们。在面对它们时，我可以告诉病人：“我不知道该怎么做，我不知道该如何面对这些事情，但它们是真实的，你的感觉看起来是真的。”我打开新闻，人们试图让我为这些
culture war things and it's like i can't really afford american cheese as somebody who makes like a pretty good salary for my kids when they want to have a sandwich in the park like can we talk about that can we talk about roads can we talk about health care and we're so far beyond that where the things that we're talking about are so many levels of like pretending to be things that other people pretended in the 80s that even they didn't believe and it seems so alienating and confusing. So, you know, I didn't understand the line that James Hillman was really, he was a Jungian analyst I've talked about before, but Hillman was really fond of quoting Auden, W.H. Auden, the poet. And I never really understood his fondness for this line until recently. And I've come around to it, but it's, we are lived by forces that we pretend
文化战争的事情争吵，而我作为一个收入还不错的人，甚至连给孩子们在公园吃三明治买美国奶酪的钱都快付不起了。我们能谈谈这个吗？我们能谈谈道路吗？我们能谈谈医疗保健吗？我们已经远远超出了那个阶段，我们谈论的事情在很多层面上都是在假装成别人在80年代假装的东西，即使是他们自己也不相信，这看起来太疏离和令人困惑了。所以，我不理解James Hillman的那句话，他是一位我之前提到过的荣格分析师，但Hillman非常喜欢引用诗人W.H. Auden的话。直到最近，我才真正理解他为什么喜欢这一行。我已经想通了，那就是：我们被我们假装理解的力量所生活。
to understand. You know, the real stuff of our lives is coming through us. And by the time we think we know why we did it, that's gone, right? It's, you know, this kind of rope of life is just being pulled through you, um, in this way that's kind of depersonalizing there. Um, there's a line that I wish I could remember from, Prophet, that book. I should have grabbed that book. I always try and grab a bunch of things I might need to get into when I start to freestyle and then I don't always remember everything that might pop into my head over the course of an hour. But, you know, Auden's line, that highlights like how the frameworks and philosophies that we resort to for certainty, when we want certainty,
我们生命中真正的东西正在通过我们发生。当我们认为我们知道为什么这样做时，那已经过去了，对吧？这就像生命的绳索以一种去个人化的方式穿过你。我希望我能记得《先知》那本书里的一句话。我本该拿那本书的。我总是试图在我开始即兴发挥时抓取一堆我可能需要的东西，但我并不总是记得在这一小时内可能出现在我脑海中的所有东西。但是，Auden的那句话强调了当我们想要确定性、想要秩序、想要感到稳定时，我们所诉诸的框架和哲学是多么虚幻。有时这是一种有益的或必要的错觉，但它们不是真实的。这种宗教、科学、政治以及所有我们觉得应该给我们某种确定性的宏大意义构建系统正在失败。因此，当我们将经验科学和所有这些力量放在基座上并期望它们为我们做这些事，但它们不再起作用时，我们感受到了所有的焦虑，我们顽固地坚持这些概念和这些超现实的模拟，因为另一种选择是承认存在歧义、矛盾和我们所有人都在经历的不可估量的怀疑。这似乎太不稳定了。所以“图像圈”（iconosphere）是哲学家鲍德里亚的一个概念。
when we want order, when we want to feel stabilizing, they're kind of delusional. Sometimes it's a helpful delusion or a necessary one, but they're not real. And this grand meaning-making system of religion and science and politics and all this stuff that we feel like is supposed to give us some kind of certainty is failing to and so this cultural dominance when we put these forces of empirical science and all these things on this pedestal and expect them to do this for us but they're not doing it anymore you know we are feeling all of this anxiety and we cling you know tenaciously to these conceptual concepts and these hyper-real simulations because the alternative would be admitting that there's ambiguity, there's contradiction, there's unfathomable doubt that we all are having. And that seems like it would be too destabilizing. So the iconosphere is an idea by a philosopher, Baudrillard.
（注：此处原文有误，应为鲍德里亚 Jean Baudrillard）
And one of my friends did an art... Actually, I don't know if he finished it. He might listen to this. But anyway, he did a... I'm remembering the first time he told me about it, which is a story I'm not going to tell. But he told me about this idea when he was reading a lot of this philosophical school called the simulacra, which is something that is a copy, but it doesn't have an original.
我的一位朋友做了一件艺术品……其实我不知道他是否完成了。他可能会听这个。但无论如何，他做了一个……我记得他第一次告诉我这件事的时候，那是一个我不会讲的故事。但他告诉我这个想法时，他正在读很多被称为“拟像”（simulacra）的哲学流派，这是一种复制品，但它没有原件。
It's sort of a copy that replaced the original, but the original also was never real. So you get this paradox there because a copy is supposed to be a copy. And so when you say, okay, it's a copy copy but then there isn't a thing that it copied you have all of this you know philosophical stuff you can dig into if you want to drink some um bordeaux and uh make undergraduates miserable in france and so like the the econosphere is this conceptual idea um that jean beaugard talks about which you know i'm not you know know, I'm not, you know, a philosopher, I'm not an expert in any of these things, but there's this idea that, um, the iconosphere is this place, this sphere where there's these images that circulate and they multiply and they create
这是一种取代了原件的复制品，但原件本身也从未真实存在过。所以你得到了这个悖论，因为复制品应该是复制品。当你问，好吧，它是复制品的复制品，但没有它所复制的东西时，如果你想喝点波尔多红酒，让法国的本科生感到痛苦，你就可以深入研究所有这些哲学东西。所以，“图像圈”是让·鲍德里亚谈论的一个概念性想法。我不是哲学家，也不是这些方面的专家，但有这样一个想法：图像圈是一个地方，一个图像循环、增殖并创造
this hyper reality that creates the real world. And that we're in this place where we're seeing all this stuff that is like real vivid, more than real. But at the same time, those were the images. They don't really represent anything anymore. Um, they're referring to this external reality that is outside of reality, but then the hyper reality of reality is telling you that this is all there is. And so there's this sort of gaslighting effect of that, um, where we feel like, you know, the world that we're in is self-referential, it's self-generating, and there's something outside of it, but also the world is telling you that there's nothing outside of the world you're in. And so some key ideas here, you know, the realm with the simulacra, those copies and those simulations have replaced the original
这种创造现实世界的超现实的地方。我们正处于这样一个地方，我们看到所有这些东西，它们看起来很真实、生动，比真实更真实。但同时，那些是图像。它们不再真正代表任何东西。它们指的是现实之外的外部现实，但现实的超现实性却告诉你这就是全部。所以有一种煤气灯操纵效应，我们觉得我们所处的世界是自我指涉的、自我生成的，世界之外有东西，但世界也告诉你，你所处的世界之外什么都没有。所以这里有一些关键的想法：拟像的领域，那些复制品和模拟已经取代了原件
and the authentic thing. A lot of correlations with something like LI, uh, AI or LLMs, the large language models that's going on now where, you know, you can look at it and you may, your brain may think it's real for a second, but another part of your brain says, no, like, I don't, I feel something bad with some of these images or some of this writing where you're halfway through an article and then all of a sudden it doesn't work. Um, but you don't know why it didn't work, you know, because of the grammar's right. It's real, but something knows it's not real. Um, and so this world of appearances and surfaces, all depth and meaning are lost. You're cut off from a source that these things used to point to, but it's no longer there. And in this realm of fascination and seduction where these images, they captivate you and they manipulate you, but also they're not real.
和真实的东西。这与现在正在发生的人工智能或大语言模型有很多关联，你可以看着它，你的大脑可能会有一秒钟认为它是真实的，但你大脑的另一部分会说：“不，我不觉得……”我对其中一些图像或写作感到不舒服，你读到文章的一半，突然它就不行了。但你不知道为什么它不行，因为语法是正确的。它是真实的，但某种东西知道它不是真实的。所以这个表象和表面的世界，所有的深度和意义都丧失了。你与这些东西曾经指向的源头隔绝了，但它已不复存在。在这个充满迷恋和诱惑的领域，这些图像吸引你、操纵你，但它们也不是真实的。
But then you are real and their effect on you becomes reality, which is sort of what I think he's getting at. You know, again, not a philosopher, not into a lot of these schools. I understand their influence and their ideas. And when they're relevant to something, I don't, you know, I can't teach a class on this, but, you know, in this world of illusion and virtualness, you know, it's virtual reality, right? A lot of these people I think are anticipating and describing virtual reality before virtual reality exists through intuition. They're in touch with these ideas. And it doesn't mean that you can see the future, but you can sort of see what society is doing, like this direction that it's going in.
但你是真实的，它们对你的影响变成了现实，这大概就是他想表达的意思。再说一次，我不是哲学家，不了解很多这些流派。我理解它们的影响和思想。当它们与某事相关时，我不能教这门课，但在这种幻觉和虚拟的世界里，这是虚拟现实，对吧？我认为很多人在虚拟现实存在之前，通过直觉就在预见和描述它。他们与这些想法保持联系。这并不意味着你能看到未来，但你可以看到社会正在做什么，就像它正在前进的方向。
That even after you're dead or 100 years after you're dead, it's not going to stop because you see these balls rolling and you know where that leads. And that's how they come to these ideas i think um so the implications of this like iconosphere unraveling is there's the symbolic order and it's profoundly disorienting like it's upsetting and you're always bombarded by these images or you know spectacles you know i'm hearing a voice of another person I went to school with a long, long time ago. But it produces this crisis of meaning and this sort of like impenetrable distance from you and the thing that is close to you, that you're right next to. So all these paradoxes and tensions here. And so these signs and reputations, they become unhinged from anything that they used to be hinged to.
即使在你死后或死后100年，它也不会停止，因为你看到了这些滚动的球，你知道它会导致什么。我认为他们就是这样得出这些想法的。所以，这种图像圈瓦解的含义是，存在着象征秩序，它让人感到深刻的迷失方向，令人不安，你总是被这些图像或奇观轰炸。我听到了很久以前和我一起上学的人的声音。但这产生了一种意义危机，以及你和你身边的事物之间那种不可逾越的距离。所以这里有所有的悖论和张力。因此，这些符号和声誉与它们曾经挂钩的任何东西脱节了。
They used to point to something, but what they point to is something we don't remember anymore. Reality becomes a dead language where we can see the script and we can say, well, I think this comes from, you know, an early Semitic language. I think that this is, you know, maybe like a proto runic script because it looks sort of like modern, but we don't even know what it's trying to say. But it's all that we have to hold on to and you know when i so sitting with that remember in high school when you had to read t.s elliott's the wasteland you know and one of the first line is that you know only a heap of broken images right so you know this crisis of meaning um that is is so that a french philosopher is talking about well here's a British guy at the end of World War one who everybody did the thing that they thought that you had to do because it made life good you put on the uniform
它们曾经指向某物，但它们指向的东西是我们不再记得的。现实变成了一种死语言，我们可以看到脚本，我们可以说：“嗯，我认为这来自一种早期的闪米特语。我认为这可能是一种原始符文脚本，因为它看起来有点像现代的，但我们甚至不知道它想说什么。”但这是我们唯一能抓住的东西。记得高中时你必须读T.S.艾略特的《荒原》吗？第一行之一就是“只有一堆破碎的图像”，对吧？所以这种意义危机，一位法国哲学家正在谈论，而这是一位一战结束时的英国人，每个人都做了他们认为必须做的事，因为这让生活变得美好。你穿上制服，
you marched out you went and you did it glory and country and all of a sudden it's not working anymore the machine gun doesn't care how brave you are you know the trenches have destroyed this country. And so, so much of the wasteland, which I really like, I could talk about the wasteland for an hour. I do like the wasteland. Um, like I do like Elliot a lot there, there are all these things that you are like witnessing an image and then you're almost starting to have an emotional connection to it. A lot of times those images are upsetting. Like you don't like it, like the conversation about getting new teeth. And, you know, this person cheating on their husband, like you're, you're affected by it, but you're it's not good.
你行军，你去了，你做了，为了荣耀和国家，突然间它不再起作用了。机枪不在乎你有多勇敢，战壕摧毁了这个国家。所以，《荒原》中有太多我非常喜欢的东西，我可以谈论《荒原》一个小时。我确实喜欢《荒原》。就像我非常喜欢艾略特，有所有这些东西，你就像在见证一个图像，然后你几乎开始与它产生情感联系。很多时候这些图像是令人不安的。你不喜欢它，比如关于换新牙的对话，以及这个人欺骗她的丈夫，你受到了影响，但它并不好。
But then before you can even react to the badness of it, you're ripped away from it. The whole wasteland is like this shifting kaleidoscope. It's it's kind of an upsetting poem to read, but in a way that is really interesting because it is giving voice to this thing that I think we all feel, not through philosophy and kind of, you know, deconstructive, you know, postmodernism, but through poetry. And this heap of broken images that he's talking about in the very beginning, I think that's what he's telling you. He's like, I'm not going to even tell you this story. I'm just going to let you feel a little bit of what it's like and where we're going here.
但在你还没来得及对它的糟糕做出反应之前，你就被从它身边拉开了。整个《荒原》就像这个不断变化的万花筒。读这首诗让人感到不安，但以一种非常有趣的方式，因为它为我们所有人感受到的东西发出了声音，不是通过哲学和解构主义、后现代主义，而是通过诗歌。他在开头提到的那堆破碎的图像，我认为那就是他想告诉你的。他就像是说：“我甚至不会告诉你这个故事。我只是要让你感受一下它是什么样子，以及我们要去向何方。”
And, you know, that theme is very similar to, you know, and if you want to jump back and listen to me talk about it, that mysticism versus objective, or not objectivism, the objective versus the mystical, that episode, I cover this, but Edward Edinger, you know, the post-Jungian, he's a Jungian analyst, and he says basically that there's an objective part of our brain that what we can taste, touch, and feel, which I'm going to say with more neurological, you know, science available to me than Edinger, that is the prefrontal cortex. That's a lot of these event-related potentials that are using the front of my brain and then there's a mystical base of the brain um mysticism that is yes trauma is stored there so a lot of those reactions are
这个主题与——如果你想跳回去听我谈论它——神秘主义与客观主义，或者不是客观主义，客观与神秘，那一集我涵盖了这个。爱德华·埃丁格（Edward Edinger），那位后荣格派，他是一位荣格分析师，他基本上说我们大脑中有一个客观的部分，我们可以尝、摸、感觉到，我会用比埃丁格更多的神经科学知识来说，那就是前额叶皮层。那是很多利用我大脑前部的事件相关电位，然后还有一个大脑的神秘基础，神秘主义，是的，创伤储存在那里，所以很多那些反应是
like unpleasant and upsetting but also like my intuition you know maybe my soul if you want to get really mystical these things that don't fit into language, they don't fit into knowledge, but they're still real. How do I know that they're real? Because the person is back being like an enlightened atheist or a scientist being like, oh, you think your emotions are real? I know they're real because I can see every single person acting on all of this archetypal energy and I can read history and I can see that that never ended and that that probably never will. So yeah, they're real. Okay. Um, and these two parts
不愉快的、令人不安的，但也像我的直觉，也许是我的灵魂，如果你想变得非常神秘的话，这些不符合语言、不符合知识的东西，但它们仍然是真实的。我怎么知道它们是真实的？因为那个人回来时像一个开明的无神论者或科学家，说：“哦，你认为你的情绪是真实的？”我知道它们是真实的，因为我可以看到每个人都在根据所有这些原型能量行事，我可以阅读历史，我可以看到那从未结束，而且可能永远不会结束。所以是的，它们是真实的。好的。大脑的这两个部分，
of the brain, the subjective, which is the emotional, um, uh, and the, um, you know, maybe it's sort of childish from one perspective, but it's also, if it's overindulged, but it also is like our intuition, which tells us like what our purpose is. And like, if we're happy and if something is just good, you know, like when I look at the direction culture is going with these large language models and these different things, I just know that it's bad. Like I know it's cutting,
主观的，也就是情感的，也许从一个角度看是幼稚的，但如果过度沉溺，它也是我们的直觉，它告诉我们我们的目的是什么。如果我们快乐，如果某事是好的，你知道，就像当我看到文化在这些大语言模型和这些不同事物上的发展方向时，我只是知道它是坏的。我知道它在切割，
not because I'm afraid of it, but because I feel like it's moving in the direction where we're putting more and more resources away from the things that make us human, like education and community and psychology and not connection with nature and a take your shoes off and go to a Dave Matthews concert, you know, the hippie way, but like connection with nature in a way that like we need it to live. And if we don't have a planet, we die, you know, big things like that. I can, yeah, make a logical argument for that, but I'm realizing, you know, the logical argument that I'm making is because I feel this intuitively first and that isn't coming from this logical place.
不是因为我害怕它，而是因为我觉得它正在朝着我们把越来越多的资源从让我们成为人的东西上移走的方向发展，比如教育、社区、心理学，而不是与自然的连接，不是那种脱掉鞋子去参加Dave Matthews音乐会的那种嬉皮方式，而是像我们需要它来生存的那种与自然的连接。如果我们没有地球，我们就死了，你知道，像这样的大事。我可以为之做出逻辑论证，但我意识到，我所做的逻辑论证是因为我首先直观地感受到了这一点，而那并不是来自这个逻辑的地方。
So Edinger says, you know, like these two things, the subjective and the objective, there are two parts of the brain. You know, one is glommed on as a newer addition, basically, through evolution. And they don't want to be in the same head. And so they tend to kind of fight and repress each other and you know a lot of what freud is trying to describe with the unconscious and imperfect language that i don't like and a lot of freud's biases built into that you know jung refines in a way that i think makes it a lot more universal and explains a lot more like history and mythology and culture and like early latent psychology a lot better than Freud's model does, you know, like, you want to go back to the Venus of Willendorf and talk about like the id, like,
所以埃丁格说，这两个东西，主观和客观，是大脑的两个部分。一个是作为进化过程中的新添加物粘在一起的。它们不想在同一个脑袋里。所以它们倾向于互相争斗和压抑。你知道弗洛伊德试图用不完美的语言描述的很多东西，我不喜欢，而且弗洛伊德的很多偏见都建立在其中。荣格以一种我认为更具普遍性的方式对其进行了提炼，并且比弗洛伊德的模型更好地解释了历史、神话、文化和早期潜伏心理学。你知道，你想回到威伦多夫的维纳斯并谈论本我（id），
it just doesn't work in the way that Jung's model describes that. And so same thing here, right? You know, I don't want to lose the thread too much by qualifying Edinger, but you have the idea of the iconosphere you have the idea of the wasteland you know and there are you know from a jungian perspective at the core of our human experience there are these archetypal energies that are biological unconscious drives they defy reason but they are still part of us and that you so you know edinger is is going through that and he has a picture that he draws where he's like you know thank god for the catholic church or something well i mean he doesn't say this in the picture but he like he shows like here's a religious or political system that is functioning well and here's yourself and it has all these archetypes
它在荣格模型描述的方式下根本行不通。所以这里也是一样，对吧？我不想通过限定埃丁格来失去线索，但你有图像圈的想法，你有荒原的想法，从荣格的角度来看，在我们人类经验的核心，有这些原型能量，它们是生物性的无意识驱动力，它们违背理性，但它们仍然是我们的一部分。埃丁格正在经历这些，他画了一张图，他说：“感谢上帝有天主教会之类的。”好吧，我的意思是他在画中没有这么说，但他展示了：这是一个运作良好的宗教或政治系统，这是你自己，它有所有的原型，
that it's projecting out that they don't have to directly encounter the divine they don't have to directly um be in touch with this archetypal source because that community is telling you oh you want to be a helper go be a social worker your your church is saying you want to do something with the messianic energy here's jesus here's the messiah oh here's the good mother you know the virgin mary you know, the Virgin Mary, you know, like, you know, our culture and our democracy does that too. You don't have to be religious, you don't have to be Catholic, but you're being told, like, you don't have to go out and figure out what to do with these from the beginning of reality. Like, you're a caveman, there's a whole cultural construct that teaches you to hold these archetypes so when you have and it can be a secular deity but you know he even says on his diagram i think um i'll try and look up where i
它投射出来，他们不必直接面对神性，不必直接接触这个原型源头，因为那个社区在告诉你：“哦，你想成为一个帮助者，去当社会工作者吧。”你的教会说：“你想用弥赛亚能量做点什么，这是耶稣，这是弥赛亚。哦，这是好母亲，你知道，圣母玛利亚。”你知道，我们的文化和民主也这样做。你不必是宗教信徒，你不必是天主教徒，但你被告知，你不必从现实的开端去弄清楚该怎么处理这些。就像你是一个穴居人，有一个完整的文化结构教你持有这些原型，所以当你拥有它时——它可以是一个世俗的神——但他甚至在他的图表上说，我想……我会试着查一下我在哪里
took a picture of the book a long time ago because the book has long been lost but um that's one of those books i think i've bought like five times that and dominion of the dead is another one that robert poke Harrison like there's some books that i i think i i would i probably spent more than like three hundred dollars buying paperback copies of some books. But like the secular deity could be capitalism, like it could be communism. And when it breaks down, and he quotes in this diagram, he quotes Eliot. He doesn't say that, but I guess he thinks that you would be familiar with it. But he says there's this heap of broken images where all of a sudden there's nothing containing these forces.
很久以前拍了那本书的照片，因为那本书早就丢了。但那是那些我想我已经买了五次的书之一，那本和罗伯特·波克·哈里森的《死者的统治》是另一本。有些书我想我可能花了超过300美元买平装本。但世俗的神可以是资本主义，可以是共产主义。当它崩溃时，他在这个图表中引用了艾略特。他没有说，但我猜他认为你会熟悉它。但他说是有一堆破碎的图像，突然间没有什么东西能容纳这些力量。
Like I'm just going out and I'm feeling something and I'm having to figure out what to do with it. Even if I figure out a couple of them, I'm not going to figure out all of them right. And if society and our religious and political systems are in crisis, all of that energy just hits you and you can't figure out what to do with it. And you start acting on intuition in a way that is unconscious and that is bad. And what that looks like is neurosis and psychosis um it can look a lot like schizophrenia you look at some of the conspiracy theories here and i'm not telling you which one to believe or not to believe but if you look at them you can look at the same people and it's like the next day they're like well the 5g is going through the aliens and whatever and you're like wait a minute i thought you said that there was a secret pedophile cabal and that like this person did
就像我只是走出去，我感觉到了一些东西，我必须弄清楚该怎么处理它。即使我弄清楚了其中的几个，我也不会把它们全部弄清楚，对吧？如果社会和我们的宗教、政治系统处于危机中，所有的能量都会冲击你，你不知道该怎么处理它。你开始以一种无意识且糟糕的方式凭直觉行事。那看起来就是神经症和精神病，它看起来很像精神分裂症。你看看这里的一些阴谋论，我不是在告诉你该相信哪一个，但如果你看看它们，你可以看同样的人，第二天他们就像：“嗯，5G正在通过外星人……”等等，你会说：“等一下，我以为你说有一个秘密的恋童癖阴谋集团，而且这个人做了……”
yeah yeah that too but no no there's a new it's like no but that isn't consistent like you're saying a different thing every day and these things don't fit together well it's because it's archetypal it's not logical you know right like there the system has broken to where we're feeling all of this stuff we're looking at this world where it is failing to contain um reason essentially like it's not making We're looking at it, and the people who are saying these things don't even look like they believe it anymore. They don't even look like they're trying to. And that creates this dissonance of like, well, this world must not be real, so what is real is this thing that I can feel. And there is a danger to that. And again, this isn't a new thing. You know, like I talked in our cults and conspiracy theories a lot series about how like when these systems break down
“是的，是的，那个也是，但不，不，有一个新的……”这就像，不，那不一致，你每天都在说不同的事情，这些东西根本不合逻辑。这是因为它是原型的，它不是逻辑的，对吧？系统已经崩溃到我们正在感受所有这些东西，我们看着这个世界，它无法容纳理性，本质上它没有意义。我们看着它，那些说这些话的人看起来甚至不再相信它了。他们看起来甚至不像是在尝试。这产生了一种不和谐感，就像：“好吧，这个世界一定不是真实的，所以真实的是我能感觉到的东西。”这有危险。再说一次，这不是什么新鲜事。你知道，我在我们的“邪教和阴谋论”系列中谈了很多关于当这些系统在历史上崩溃时，
historically, people do start to say they believe in magic. They start to, because you know, when people are in crisis, they gravitate towards a magical system. They gravitate towards making meaning that way. And, you know, so Edinger is another, and what I'm trying to do is throw a bunch of people at you that are saying the same thing, I think, from a different perspective, intuitively, with very different language. Because I think that when you go into these places intuitively and you confront these things honestly, and you don't discard science and just call yourself a wizard, it's fine to do that. But if you don't do that and you try and understand the role that science can play, but you don't limit yourself by the role science can play, you also are in touch with this kind of archetypal and inherently subjective part of the brain that you just can't objectify it. You can't
人们确实开始说他们相信魔法。他们开始……因为你知道，当人们处于危机中时，他们会被吸引到魔法系统中。他们会被吸引到以那种方式创造意义。所以，埃丁格是另一个，我试图做的是向你们抛出一堆人，我认为他们从不同的角度、直觉上、用非常不同的语言在说同样的事情。因为我认为当你直观地进入这些地方并诚实地面对这些事情时，你不要抛弃科学并称自己为巫师——这样做是可以的。但如果你不这样做，你试图理解科学可以发挥的作用，但你不限制自己，你也接触到了大脑中这种原型且本质上主观的部分，你无法将其客观化。你不能
turn it into a screener, you know? Like we can't turn everything that we're going to work with in therapy into something that we can assess with a number. We just can't. Um, when you, when you sit with both of them, you end up saying this, something like the iconosphere, like the wasteland, like ego and archetype, the Edward Nettinger book, you say something kind of like the lens that Nietzsche uses. You know, Nietzsche sees logic as a form of insecurity, which is really interesting to me, because it's true. Like, when he's writing, what he's saying is he's looking for these people who are very logical empirical either philosophers or scientists that are looking for these like very rational examinations of truth they think there's an
把它变成一个筛查工具，对吧？我们不能把我们在治疗中要处理的一切都变成我们可以用数字评估的东西。我们就是不能。当你坐下来面对这两者时，你最终会说出类似图像圈、荒原、自我与原型（爱德华·埃丁格的书）的东西，你会说出类似尼采使用的镜头的东西。你知道，尼采将逻辑视为一种不安全感，这对我来说非常有趣，因为这是真的。当他在写作时，他所说的是他在寻找那些非常逻辑、经验主义的哲学家或科学家，他们正在寻找对真理的非常理性的检验，他们认为如果他们能转动他们的智力齿轮，
absolute truth that they can find if they can just spin their intellectual gears you know wheels enough and and that he sees that as this confession that those people are terrified and anxious and looking for a certainty that is not real it was like um that you would build this monument to your intellect and your ego only when you are so afraid that you're gonna die and not matter and be unimportant and that no one would do that if they don't think that way right like if you have a whole society build you a pyramid a giant pyramid you're kind of afraid of dying, right? Because that pyramid is telling on you, hey, the Pharaoh thinks that they're going to not live. And so they've made this whole thing of if I make this insane tomb with all these traps
他们就能找到绝对真理。他认为这是一种忏悔，那些人感到恐惧和焦虑，正在寻找一种不真实的确定性。就像你会为你自己的智力和自我建立这座纪念碑，只有当你非常害怕你会死、变得无关紧要、不重要时，如果人们不那样想，就不会有人那样做，对吧？如果整个社会为你建造一座金字塔，一座巨大的金字塔，你有点害怕死亡，对吧？因为那座金字塔在告发你：“嘿，法老认为他们不会活下去。”所以他们制造了这一切，如果我制造了这个带有所有陷阱的疯狂坟墓……
and my body stays there, the Ba and the Ka will come out and it'll go visit my relatives. Basically, everything that I want to do, you know, I have to make it hard and that makes it real. Right. And then I have to involve the culture in it and that's going to make it real. You know, that's the Pharaoh doesn't want to die. Okay. You know, the pyramids are a great example of something that serves like no practical strategic military, even political purpose. Like everyone resented the pyramids. They were a big point of contention it's only a psychological thing for the leadership you know to have that and so there there's like so much truth in what nietzsche's doing when he he says that you know science and philosophy um obsession with science and philosophy
当我的身体留在那里时，巴（Ba）和卡（Ka）就会出来，去探望我的亲戚。基本上，我想做的每一件事，你知道，我都必须让它变得困难，而这会让它变得真实。没错。然后我必须把文化融入其中，这会让它变得真实。你知道，法老不想死。好吧。你知道，金字塔就是一个很好的例子，它在实际的战略、军事甚至政治上都没有什么用处。就像每个人都怨恨金字塔一样。它们是一个巨大的争议点，对领导层来说，这只是一种心理上的东西，你知道，拥有那个东西。所以，尼采所说的关于科学和哲学，嗯，对科学和哲学的痴迷，其中有太多的真理了。
with the logical nature of those things the empirical nature of those things he's not against them but when there's this obsession with the empirical and objective parts of them taken to an extreme, it's an unconsciously projected psychological struggle. And that you can use that to analyze, psychoanalyze, you know, the author of these works. And there's so much truth in that. Like when I had a patient come in one time, I've actually had a couple of people come in, um, cause they see existential, there's a joke. Okay. There's a joke that like we make it consultation groups sometimes that like when a patient sees existential therapy on your bio and they come in because they want to talk to an existentialist, the last thing that they actually need is existentialism. Um, I've had multiple patients that have come in and
对于这些事物的逻辑本质，对于这些事物的经验本质，他并不反对，但当这种对经验和客观部分的痴迷被推向极端时，这是一种无意识投射的心理斗争。你可以利用这一点来分析，心理分析，你知道，这些作品的作者。这其中有太多的真理。就像有一次我的一位病人来访，实际上我有几个人来访，嗯，因为他们看到了存在主义，这是一个笑话。好吧。有一个笑话，我们有时会在咨询小组中说，当病人看到你的简历上有存在主义疗法，他们来是因为他们想和一个存在主义者交谈，而他们真正最不需要的就是存在主义。嗯，我有好几个病人来过，并且
have quoted that, um, Oh, what's his name? I don't remember that have come in and have quoted that um oh what's his name I don't remember that anyway they've quoted the French play where they say you know that hell is other people and when they say that I know this that isn't relevant like what other people do or what you're how other people like the point what you're telling me is that I feel like I'm in hell and so that's where I start, you know, as a therapist. And so, you know, Nietzsche's arguing that these more philosophical work, they present, you know, the people that present this stuff as just pure logical analysis, that's going to get to this truth. That's kind of this grandiose insane claim that lets you know
引用了那个，嗯，哦，他叫什么名字？我不记得了，他们来过，引用了那个，嗯，哦，他叫什么名字？我不记得了，总之，他们引用了那部法国戏剧，他们说，你知道，他人即地狱。当他们这么说的时候，我知道这并不相关，就像其他人做什么，或者你是，其他人如何，就像重点是，你告诉我的是，我觉得我身处地狱，所以这就是我作为治疗师的切入点。所以，你知道，尼采认为这些更具哲学性的作品，它们呈现，你知道，那些把这些东西仅仅当作纯粹逻辑分析来呈现的人，那将会触及这个真理。这是一种宏大而疯狂的主张，让你知道
that they're crazy. Um, or, you know, crazy. That's, I don't, I don't mean to be, um, too hard on some of the people that Nietzsche talks about, but like they're cut off from this other part of themselves that they don't want to be real in a way. Right. He's saying the same thing that Edinger says. I don't think if you got these guys at a table that they would all agree and be like, Oh yeah, we all figured out the same thing. I don't think that at all. That's not what I'm saying. I'm saying that they're responding to solving the same tension and in a way that is unique to them, which is really what we as therapists and patients, as we move into this modern realm, like that's kind of what we all should be doing and teaching our patients to do. Like if there's a future for therapy,
他们疯了。嗯，或者，你知道，疯狂。我不是，我不是想对尼采谈论的一些人太苛刻，但他们与自己的另一部分隔绝了，在某种程度上，他们不想让那部分变得真实。没错。他说的和埃丁格（Edinger）说的是同一件事。我不认为如果你把这些人聚在一张桌子旁，他们都会同意并说，哦，是的，我们都弄明白了同样的事情。我一点也不这么认为。我不是那个意思。我的意思是，他们是在回应解决同样的紧张关系，并且以一种对他们来说独特的方式，这实际上就是我们作为治疗师和病人，当我们进入这个现代领域时，我们都应该做的事情，并教导我们的病人去做。如果治疗有未来，
if you want to find a point to this article or this essay, it's well, this list of notes that I'm reading, then I'll probably, um, you know, try to get, you know, an LLM to transcribe what I'm done talking is and put it on the blog is like that. We have to make patients with these tensions and figure out their own language and their own way to do this. If there's a future for therapy, it's that, you know, amidst all of this broken images, it's not more logic. Um, it isn't more of the things that are failing and it isn't pretending that those things aren't failing. That's the worst thing that we can do. Um, it's in the same way that you can feel right? You can find your model for therapy. You
如果你想在这篇文章或这篇论文中找到一个重点，好吧，我正在读的这份笔记清单，那么我可能会，嗯，你知道，试着让，你知道，一个大语言模型（LLM）把我讲完的内容转录出来，然后把它放在博客上，就像那样。我们必须让病人面对这些紧张关系，并找出他们自己的语言和他们自己的方式来做到这一点。如果治疗有未来，那就是，你知道，在所有这些破碎的意象中，不是更多的逻辑。嗯，不是更多那些正在失败的东西，也不是假装那些东西没有失败。那是我们能做的最糟糕的事情。嗯，就像你能感觉到一样，对吧？你可以找到你的治疗模型，你
can find your model for being a person in life, you know, to heal yourself through Nietzsche, Edinger, you know, the idea of the iconosphere, a poem like The Wasteland, a million other examples if I had, you know, another day, you know, to think about the stuff I would come up with, or kind of reconciling the same tension. And you can see that these people don't agree. They're not doing it the same way, but they kind of are, right? And that's the paradox, if you want to look for a point of this. So, I mean, instead of trying to, like, impose these pre-existing frameworks of meaning onto a patient's existence, they come to me meaningless, and then I give them a framework for making
可以在生活中找到你作为人的模型，你知道，通过尼采、埃丁格，你知道，意象圈（iconosphere）的概念，像《荒原》这样的诗，如果我有，你知道，另一天，你知道，去思考这些东西，我还会想出一百万个其他的例子，或者说是调和同样的紧张关系。你可以看到这些人并不认同。他们不是以同样的方式做这件事，但他们又确实是，对吧？这就是悖论，如果你想寻找这一点的话。所以，我的意思是，与其试图将这些预先存在的意义框架强加给病人的存在，他们来到我这里时是无意义的，然后我给他们一个制造意义的框架。
meaning. I think we have to make them make their own meaning, which is harder therapy to do. It's hard to teach because the therapist has to sit with their uncertainty too, to teach the patient to do it. That's why I'm not telling you how to do this. I'm not saying how I do it. You know, I'm saying, I'm trying to get you to feel it, you know, when I, when I write something like this. So like, you know, by learning to let go of this need for certainty and control and cultivate the sense of openness and creativity in the face of the unknown, you know, the patient can begin to discover themselves in a more authentic and empowering way. But there's long dark nights of the soul here.
我认为我们必须让他们自己创造意义，这是一种更难的治疗方式。这很难教，因为治疗师也必须与他们的不确定性共处，才能教病人这样做。这就是为什么我不告诉你怎么做。我不是在说我是怎么做的。你知道，我的意思是，当我写这样的东西时，我是在试图让你感受到它。所以，你知道，通过学习放下这种对确定性和控制的需求，并在面对未知时培养一种开放和创造的感觉，你知道，病人可以开始以一种更真实和赋权的方式发现自己。但这里有漫长而黑暗的灵魂之夜。
It's hard, right? You know, what's the Simone Bay quote about that? When the patient is in the labyrinth, we or not the patient, but the person is in the labyrinth, you're walking on this dark track and you don't even know if you're going in a circle. It feels like that, that knowing that you have to keep walking, even if you may just be walking in a circle until you starve and die is part of the process that you have to face in order to heal. That you have to keep going, even knowing that you going somewhere may mean that you have to face in order to heal. That you have to keep going, even knowing that you going somewhere may mean that you're not going anywhere. That you have to go through that.
这很难，对吧？你知道，西蒙娜·薇依（Simone Weil）关于那件事的引言是什么？当病人在迷宫中时，我们，或者不是病人，而是那个人在迷宫中，你在那条黑暗的轨道上行走，你甚至不知道你是否在绕圈子。感觉就是那样，那种知道你必须继续走下去的感觉，即使你可能只是在绕圈子，直到你饿死，这也是你为了治愈而必须面对的过程的一部分。你必须继续前进，即使知道你走向某个地方可能意味着你为了治愈而必须面对。你必须继续前进，即使知道你走向某个地方可能意味着你哪里也没去。你必须经历那个过程。
You know, and what is it, Fritz Perls? I got my Perls here. So the Gestalt therapy guy said, you know, the aim of therapy was to help the patient come to this point where they could live with uncertainty without props. I think he says without props. Which is a funny word. That almost is perfectly referring back to something like the iconosphere.
你知道，还有什么，弗里茨·皮尔斯（Fritz Perls）？我这里有皮尔斯的书。所以那位格式塔疗法（Gestalt therapy）的家伙说，你知道，治疗的目的是帮助病人达到这一点，让他们可以在没有支撑的情况下与不确定性共存。我想他说的是没有支撑。这是一个有趣的词。这几乎完美地回指了像意象圈这样的东西。
That there's this feeling that we have to conform in order to belong. And that we have to get these things that are the symptoms of a healthy life or a happy life but we don't actually have to confront our insecurity and know what that is he says that the person has to learn you know to live by their own resources which means not the therapist resources you can't tell them how to do it and so walter benjamin is another one who, again, I'm not an expert on this, but he's reflecting on a lot of these same ideas. And he's talking about the shock experience, that we live in this culture that is constantly causing us shocks and wearing us down to nothing because this need to have constant consumption for economy under capitalism means that there has to be constant production which means that the things have to age because there has to be a new thing you know and he's writing really at the beginning of the
有一种感觉，我们必须顺从才能归属。我们必须得到那些健康生活或幸福生活的症状，但我们实际上不必面对我们的不安全感，也不知道那是什么。他说，人必须学会，你知道，依靠自己的资源生活，这意味着不是依靠治疗师的资源，你不能告诉他们怎么做。所以瓦尔特·本雅明（Walter Benjamin）是另一个人，同样，我不是这方面的专家，但他正在反思许多相同的想法。他谈到了震惊体验，我们生活在这种不断给我们造成冲击并把我们磨损到一无所有的文化中，因为资本主义下经济对持续消费的需求意味着必须有持续的生产，这意味着事物必须老化，因为必须有新的东西，你知道，他写作时确实处于
age of what would turn into a culture driven by mass production. I mean, he sees mass production, definitely, but not its effect on culture. Like now, you know, think of the news cycle as different in 12 hours. Like you sound like you're, if you're like, hey, remember the thing that was a scandal like two months ago? No one even knows what you mean.
一个会演变成由大规模生产驱动的文化的时代。我的意思是，他确实看到了大规模生产，但没有看到它对文化的影响。就像现在，你知道，想想新闻周期在12小时内是不同的。听起来就像你，如果你说，嘿，还记得两个月前那个丑闻吗？没人知道你在说什么。
You know, something like when I was a kid, the Clinton scandal, like it was like two years of like the same thing. And now like, it was like two years of the same thing. And now you don't even remember what the last thing was. Well, products do that, computer, everything has to be replaced. And that those perpetual shocks, what Benjamin is saying there, is that there's this ubiquitous experience that is kind of traumatic and is always happening.
你知道，就像我小时候，克林顿丑闻，就像两年的时间里都是同样的事情。而现在，就像两年的时间里都是同样的事情。而现在你甚至不记得上一件事是什么了。好吧，产品就是这样，电脑，一切都必须更换。而那些持续的冲击，本雅明在那里所说的是，有一种无处不在的体验，它有点创伤性，而且一直在发生。
And so we don't even feel it anymore. Like we become numb to it. And that those protective barriers that used to be ritual and tradition and collective meaning are eroded by you just having to participate in this litany of consumption and production in order to participate in culture at all. And that leaves us incredibly vulnerable. And it also makes it very hard for us to know why we're doing something, because everything that we're doing is something we have to do, not something that we want to do or something that we choose. I was thinking about that today when I wanted to like hang out with my friends and I
所以我们甚至感觉不到了。就像我们对它变得麻木了。而那些曾经是仪式、传统和集体意义的保护屏障，被你为了参与文化而不得不参与的这种消费和生产的连祷所侵蚀。这让我们变得极其脆弱。这也让我们很难知道我们为什么要这样做，因为我们所做的一切都是我们必须做的事情，而不是我们想做的事情或我们选择的事情。我今天在想，当我想和朋友们出去玩，我
took my son for a walk. And it's like one of the first times I haven't been sick for like a month and a half and just the first minute that I had and I called my friend and I was talking to him and I was realizing my neighbor up the hill had said like hey why don't we hang out and I was like in my head I was like look I don't even get to hang out with the people who I know like all I do is like work at Taproot and then see my kids if I have any time off like yeah you seem like a nice person but like I don't even get to hang out with my closest friends like when am I gonna walk up the street and do whatever when then I was kind of repulsed by that internally and was like why can't I have a community and go hang out with my neighbor he seemed like a nice guy but I'm realizing that like
带我儿子去散步时。这大概是我一个半月以来第一次没生病，我有的第一分钟，我给我的朋友打了电话，我在和他交谈，我意识到我山上的邻居曾说，嘿，我们为什么不出去玩呢？我在脑子里想，看，我甚至没时间和我认识的人出去玩，我所做的就是像在Taproot工作，然后如果我有空闲时间就见见我的孩子们，就像，是的，你看起来是个好人，但就像，我甚至没时间和我最亲密的朋友出去玩，我什么时候能走上街头做任何事呢？然后我内心对那种想法感到反感，心想为什么我不能有一个社区，去和我的邻居出去玩呢？他看起来是个好人，但我意识到，就像
and my patients were saying the same thing about like they were lonely and wanted to do this but everything that we do is something we have to do because everything is tied to this notion of production and consumption in this way that has accelerated culture so much that we really don't have that much free time and we really don't have that much choice you know like i wouldn't run a therapy collective probably if i was a millionaire and didn't have to work I just wouldn't I would do something else I would go hang out with my neighbor up the hill um but I think that that speed of culture is sort of what he's getting at there that there's these you know insights that everything I mean and I get more of like a felt texture from what I've read I'm not not at all an expert on him but it does seem like more of this kind of felt experience of
我的病人们也在说同样的事情，关于他们很孤独，想做这件事，但我们所做的一切都是我们必须做的事情，因为一切都以这种方式与生产和消费的概念联系在一起，这种方式极大地加速了文化，以至于我们真的没有那么多空闲时间，也没有那么多选择。你知道，如果我是百万富翁，不需要工作，我可能就不会经营一个治疗集体了。我只是不会。我会做别的事情，我会去和山上的邻居出去玩。但我认为那种文化的加速正是他所指出的，即存在这些，你知道，洞察力，一切，我的意思是，我从我读过的东西中得到了更多一种触感，我根本不是他的专家，但这确实看起来更像是一种
just being worn ragged by the pace of everything and giving, and that being something that's hard to do. So I'm going to try and wrap this up. Um, but that we're always in the same way that, you know, capitalism is making you produce and consume these things, um, you know, just content to have, to sell, to whatever. That's also kind of applied to culture. Like we have these inner images, we have these outer images and we're constantly like manufacturing and replacing those things. Um, and like we can start to be more aware of our inner world and we can start to understand
被一切的节奏磨得破破烂烂的触感体验，并且给予，而那是一件很难做到的事情。所以我打算试着总结一下。嗯，但我们总是以同样的方式，你知道，资本主义让你生产和消费这些东西，嗯，你知道，只是为了拥有、为了销售、为了任何目的的内容。这也适用于文化。就像我们有这些内在的意象，我们有这些外在的意象，我们不断地制造和替换那些东西。嗯，我们可以开始更多地意识到我们的内心世界，我们可以开始理解
what we've internalized. I'm trying to take something from him that I can turn back into a therapy point. And some of these images that were internalized that we have to have, my life has to be this, it has to do that or culture, whatever. I mean, that may be from a value system that's 30 years old now, or, or just not mine. You know, like look at these images that are internalized because we also project and react to those externally, you know, and, um, and make a choice. The things that you have inside of you, that's, that's an option. You know, there's, I'm not want to give like two practical language for this, um, or, or two, like, I'm not trying to make a new model of therapy here. I'm trying to point to how therapy has to change if it's going to be relevant. And some of it is just sitting with like, Hey, what did you absorb from the world? Like, is that a good thing?
我们内化了什么。我正试图从他那里拿走一些东西，我可以把它变回一个治疗点。而其中一些被内化的意象，我们必须拥有的，我的生活必须是这样的，它必须做那个，或者文化，无论什么。我的意思是，那可能来自一个30年前的价值体系，或者，或者只是不属于我的。你知道，就像看看这些被内化的意象，因为我们也向外投射并对那些东西做出反应，你知道，而且，嗯，做出一个选择。你内心拥有的东西，那是一个选项。你知道，我不想给这个提供太实用的语言，嗯，或者，或者太，我不是想在这里建立一个新的治疗模型。我是在试图指出如果治疗要保持相关性，它必须如何改变。而其中一部分只是坐下来，嘿，你从世界上吸收了什么？那是一件好事吗？
Do you want that in you? Are you participating in that thing? You know, externally, just because you have this inward image that you can discard? Or are you letting something that you think is like not real in the world, this thing from, you know, that basically is, you know, a symbol or a reality that used to be something relevant that you don't even care about and form your inner world, maybe you should have more of a filter or a barrier to that, you know, talking about these kinds of cultural forces i think is important um and so uh i know i had talked about adam carter's a couple times but the the movie that i refer to a lot because i don't think that all of his are great um i think
你想要那个在你里面吗？你是在参与那件事吗？你知道，在外部，仅仅因为你有这个可以丢弃的内在意象？或者你是否让某种你认为在世界上不真实的东西，这种来自，你知道，基本上是，你知道，一个符号或现实，曾经是某种相关的东西，而你甚至不在乎，来形成你的内心世界，也许你应该对那个有更多的过滤或屏障，你知道，谈论这些文化力量我认为很重要。嗯，所以，我知道我提过几次亚当·柯蒂斯（Adam Curtis），但我经常提到的那部电影，因为我不认为他所有的电影都很棒，我认为
that they work more i won't get into that i think the ones that are kind of metaphorical work more than the ones that are literal but um like the all-watched-over-by-machines-of-loving-grace film that Adam Curtis did that's like a documentary that's kind of deconstructing some of these cultural forces. I really like that one. But the name of it is based on – because I think if you want to pull like a point from that movie, it, cause it, it sort of defies a point. Like none of Adam Curtis's movies are ever like, we set out to prove this, but what we actually found scared us even more.
它们更有效，我不会深入探讨那个，我认为那些隐喻性的比那些字面意义上的更有效，但嗯，就像亚当·柯蒂斯制作的那部《所有人都被充满爱的机器监视着》（All Watched Over by Machines of Loving Grace），那是一部正在解构其中一些文化力量的纪录片。我真的很喜欢那一部。但它的名字是基于——因为我认为如果你想从那部电影中提取一个观点，它，因为它，它有点违背了一个观点。就像亚当·柯蒂斯的电影从来没有像，我们着手证明这一点，但我们实际发现的东西让我们更加害怕。
And what is, there's no thesis. Like it's this very felt sort of art film thing, but if you want to pull a thesis out of all watched over by machines of loving grace, like I think what he's saying is that when we started to make a culture and it got way worse way faster when we uh invented computers because it entered our you know i guess the iconosphere like it entered the way that we thought about the world which changed the way that we thought about ourselves but when we started to conceive of people like
而且是什么，没有论文。就像这是一种非常有触感的艺术电影，但如果你想从《所有人都被充满爱的机器监视着》中提取一个论点，我想他所说的是，当我们开始创造一种文化，并且当我们发明了电脑时，它变得更糟、更快，因为它进入了我们的，我猜是意象圈，就像它进入了我们思考世界的方式，这改变了我们思考自己的方式。但当我们开始把人设想为
computers that could be programmed that were just machines, that if we made the perfect circumstance to control them, that their behavior would be a hundred percent predictable, that you could design a culture. Like that's when things went south because we're not computers. Like we don't fit into a binary, you know, because like computers don't dream, you know, like computers we we are driven mad when we can't dream because we're humans and computers think in binary like they are machines for processing information um and if you want to say like oh maybe chat gpt5 is going to be sent here or something no it won't because so much of like what i've tried to say with these articles with like our line of thinking and looking at psychology in the weird
可以被编程的电脑，仅仅是机器，如果我们创造了完美的条件来控制它们，它们的行为将是百分之百可预测的，你可以设计一种文化。就像那是事情变糟的时候，因为我们不是电脑。我们不适合二进制，你知道，因为电脑不会做梦，你知道，就像电脑，当我们不能做梦时，我们会发疯，因为我们是人类，而电脑以二进制思考，就像它们是处理信息的机器。嗯，如果你想说，哦，也许ChatGPT 5会被送到这里或者什么，不，它不会，因为我试图用这些文章表达的很多东西，就像我们的思维路线和观察心理学的方式，以我们在本播客中观察它的那种奇怪的方式，就是我们的人性某种程度上来自于两个不想在同一个脑袋里的东西之间的紧张关系，而我们作为人类的很多焦虑、很多活力和美，但也包括我们的疯狂，都是在试图解决这两个不在一起的东西的悖论，它们是一个悖论，它们是互斥的，它们确实会相互湮灭，但它们不能，因为它们是同一事物的一部分，对吧？大语言模型本质上只是一个预测引擎，它只是说这个词以这种概率与这些词以这种方式连接。你想让我花多少钱在服务器的CPU上计算数字来预测这个词接下来出现在这个词旁边的可能性？如果你花很多钱，并且你设计这个LLM AI的公司的烧钱率非常高，你可以得到一个非常好的语言等价物，如果你花得不多，你可以得到一个非常糟糕的语言近似值，用比较像五年级学生的语气写作，就是这样，它不可能产生感知，因为它是一个电子表格，它是一个非常复杂的电子表格，它不是，没有使我们成为人类的哲学紧张关系，嗯，这就是我会称之为，你知道，我们的人性。所以总结一下，你知道那首诗，《所有人都被充满爱的机器监视着》是以它命名的，也就是《所有人都被充满爱的机器监视着》，诗人理查德·布劳提根（Richard Brautigan）我想是70年代的一名电气工程师，某种工程师，所以这就像太
way that we look at it on on this podcast is that our humanity kind of comes from the tension between two things that don't want to be in the same head and so much of our anxiety and so much of our vibrancy and our beauty as humans but also like our madness is trying to solve this paradox of these two things that don't go together that are a paradox they are mutually exclusive like they do annihilate yet they can't because they are part of the same thing right a large language model is essentially a just predictive engine it's just saying this word was connected to these words with this probability in this way. How much money do you want me to spend crunching the numbers in the
70年代了，我不会读完整篇，嗯，当我写完它时，我会把它放在这篇博客文章中，可能由一个LLM完成，在我转录它之后，但它就像是关于，你知道，所以是的，好吧，我明白了重点，这是它的开头，我喜欢思考，越快越好，一个控制论草地，哺乳动物和电脑生活在一起，在互惠和编程的和谐中，就像纯净的水触碰清澈的天空，我喜欢思考，现在请，一个控制论森林，充满了松树和电子，在那里鹿平静地走过电脑，仿佛它们是开着花朵旋转的花朵，好吧，这首诗很烂，他不是一个很好的诗人，但这个想法
CPU on a server to predict how likely it is that the word is going to go next to this one? And you can get a really good equivalency of language if you spend a lot of money and your burn rate is really high on your company that's designing this llm ai thing and you can get a very poor approximation of language that is writing in comparative sa you know fifth grader voice if you don't spend very much that's it that can't become sentient because it is a spreadsheet it is a very complicated spreadsheet it is not there is no philosophical tension that makes us human um which is what i would call you know our humanity um so to wrap this up you know that that poem that all watch over by machines of loving grace is named after which is all watch over by machines loving grace a poet richard brodigan is i think an electrical engineer some kind of engineer in the 70s so this is like so
在这里很有趣，这个人只是认为，基本上机器和自然，你知道，就像电脑和自然本质上是同一回事，有一天我们会某种程度上合成成同一回事，对吧？如果你玩电子游戏，或者我猜是《质量效应1》的结局，或者3，剧透警告，就像，那太疯狂了，我认为柯蒂斯采纳了它，而且这个家伙在纪录片中滔滔不绝地谈论的一件事是，他试图制作一个所有自然的电路图，因为他认为你可以把所有自然简化为这些完全经验性的客观事物，所以他试图画一个像这样的小东西，哦，你知道
70s i'm not gonna read the whole thing um i'll put it on the blog post of this when i when i get it written probably by an llm um after i transcribe it but it was like about uh you know so yeah okay so i got the point uh here's here's the beginning of it i like to think and the sooner the better of a cybernetic meadow where mammals and computers live together and mutuality and programming harmony like pure water touching clear sky i like to think right now please of a cybernetic forest filled with pines and electronics where deers stroll peacefully past computers as if they were flowers spinning with blossoms okay so the poetry sucks it's not a very good poet um but the idea
鹿吃草，所以那就像进入鹿腿电池的加5安培能量，但它必须通过鹿的消化系统的电阻，点，你知道，1.5安培变成了大便或者什么，我不知道，就像他试图用一个草地玩龙与地下城，并把一切变成，你知道，一个属性。那太狂野了。那真是太狂野了。所以那种思维，我认为，是危险的。这就是为什么我在这里提到它。所以，你知道，这些精神分析的日子，精神分析基本上以同样的方式开始。弗洛伊德说，就像，我们可以把人的每一个部分拆开，我们可以给它贴上标签，我们可以教他们那是什么。然后当他们把一切重新组合在一起时，
here that is interesting is this person just thinks that like basically machines and nature you know like computers and nature are inherently the same thing and one day we'll sort of like synthesize into the same thing right the end of mass effect one if you play video games or i guess three spoiler alert um like the that is so nuts that i think curtis takes it and one of the things that this guy did that he goes on about in the um he goes on about in the documentary is that he was trying to make a circuit diagram of all of nature because he thought you could reduce all of nature to these completely empirical objective things and so he was trying to draw like a little thing of like oh you know
嗯，它会起作用，因为他们不知道他们的汽车引擎是如何工作的。这就像，我教我15岁的孩子如何，我没有15岁的孩子，但我只是，而且弗洛伊德也没有，但好吧，我想他在某个时候有过，但他没有教她如何驾驶思域。所以就像，那个人就像，是的，我教我15岁的孩子如何驾驶思域。她知道如何检查机油。她知道如何做这个。她知道如果它坏了怎么把它拆开，无论什么。弗洛伊德认为我们可以用大脑做到这一点，就像理查德·布劳提根认为我们可以用自然做到这一点，就像亚当·柯蒂斯正在批评的那样，你知道，就像，你只是在建造这个引擎。但这行不通，你知道。如果你看看很多后
the deer eats the grass and so that's like plus five amperage of energy that goes into the battery of the deer's leg but it has to go through the resistor of the deer's uh digestive system and point you know 1.5 of the amps are turned into poop or whatever i don't know like he's trying to play dnd with a meadow and turn everything into you know an, an attribute. And that is wild. That's just real wild. So that kind of thinking, I think, is dangerous. And that's why I mentioned that in here. So, you know, these days of psychoanalysis, which psychoanalysis basically starts the same way. Freud says, like, we can take every single part of the person apart, we can label it, we can teach them what it is. And then when they put it all back together,
荣格派作家，特别是大卫·泰西（David Tacey），我真的很喜欢他，我认为他是最细致、最诚实地处理荣格作为一个人的作家之一，而且他对他，你知道，嗯，他根本没有在荣格身上投射，嗯，以许多分析师那样的方式。嗯，但泰西谈到了后世俗神圣（post-secular sacred）这个概念。如果你想读一本大卫·泰西的书，那是一本非常好的书。但他有一个想法，在时间的开始，我们相信魔法，因为我们必须相信。
um, the, it'll work because they don't know how the engine of their car works. And it's just like, I taught my 15 year old how to, I don't have a 15 year old, but I'm just, and Freud didn't either, but well, I guess he did at one point, but he didn't teach her how to drive it civic. So like, it's like the person being like, yeah, I taught my 15 year old how to drive the civic. She knows how to check the oil. She knows how to do this. She knows how to take it apart if it breaks, whatever. For we thought we could do that with a brain in the same way that Richard Brodigan thought that we could do that with nature in the same way that Adam Curtis is criticizing, you know, that, like, you were just building this engine. But that doesn't work, you know. And if you look at a lot of the post
我们正在进化。我们需要相信我们对太阳和月亮有控制权，我们只是看到了这些人类的心理支柱，我们要求它们帮助我们，喂养我们，就像无论什么，嗯，我们将我们自己的心理投射到一个死寂的世界上，嗯，这让它像我们一样活着，它成为了我们的一部分，这让我们保持健康，那是神话的第一个时代，然后科学出现了，他们说，不，不，不，那实际上是不理性的，是疯狂的。就像，不要那样做。你能做的是只是给每一个
Jungian writers, especially David Tacey, who I really like, I think he's like one of the most nuanced and honest about dealing with Jung as a person and his like real, you know, um, he doesn't project on Jung at all, um, in a way that a lot of analysts do. Um, but Tacey talks about this idea of the post-secular sacred. That's a really good book that Tacey wrote, if you want to read a David Tacey book. But he has this idea that in the beginning of time, we believed in magic because we had to.
单一的事物贴上标签，然后理解它是什么。然后你就可以只是成为，你可以通过客观主义建立任何你想要的东西。你不必处理魔法。你不必处理主观性。你不必处理不确定性。也许我们还没有弄明白，但我们会弄明白的，你会知道一切。所以与其像乞求上帝帮助你，基本上科学会，你知道，赋予我们力量，让我们觉得我们就是上帝，这，我会争辩说，是一个正在失败的世界观。因为我不知道你怎么样，但我不觉得自己像上帝。我认为年轻人感觉更糟。他们觉得他们拥有的确定性更少，然而我们拥有这种超现实、超逻辑、
We were evolving. We needed to believe that we had control over the sun and the moon, and we just saw these psychic pillars of humanity, and we asked them over the sun and the moon and we just saw these psychic pillars of humanity and we asked them to help us and feed us and like whatever and um we projected our own psychology onto a world that was dead and um and that made it alive like us it made a part of us and that kept us healthy and that was this first kind of epoch of myth and then science comes along and they say like, no, no, no, that's actually irrational and crazy. Like, don't do that. What you can do is just label like every
超生产导向、超消费导向、科学经验主义的现实，它在告诉我们我们感觉很好，但我们知道我们没有。问题是，这就是我知道这些不是逻辑现实的原因，尼采是对的，因为我们感觉不好，对吧？所以你可以做数学题，说它证明了这一点，我应该感觉很好。文化在说我应该感觉很好。我周围有所有健康生活的意象和东西。我有所有幸福的症状。但猜猜怎么着？你没有。好吧。而那个说你没有的声音是真实的。重新接触这些东西的第一步是承认它是真实的，即使你看不见它、摸不着它、尝不到它，并且
single thing and then understand what it is. And then you can just become, you can build anything you want through objectivism. You don't have to deal with magic. You don't have to deal with subjectivity. You don't have to deal with uncertainty. Maybe we haven't figured it out yet, but we will figure it out and you'll know everything. And so instead of like begging God to help you, it basically science would, you know, empower us to feel like we are the gods, which is, I would argue, a worldview that is failing. Because I don't know about you, but I don't feel like God. I think younger people feel worse. They feel like they have less certainty, yet we have this hyper real, ultra logical,
某种程度上在这些事物之间重新获得平衡。所以，你知道，那种治疗看起来像什么？再说一次，我不是在制造一个新的治疗模型，但这可能会引导我们理解内在的智慧和同情心，以及我一直在谈论的东西，而不是试图仅仅努力去完美地理解和控制。所以，你知道，病人可以开始理解，你知道，如何拥抱生活的不确定性，嗯，而且那是一件好事或一件不可避免的事情，一件可能让我们感到恐惧但也激励我们的事情，嗯，我有一个CBT治疗师，虽然我不喜欢认知疗法，但很多CBT治疗师都是很棒的治疗师，如果你给很多CBT治疗师编码，他们只是做了足够长的时间，以至于他们
ultra production focused, ultra consumption focused, scientific empirical reality that is telling us that we feel good, but we know we don't. And the thing is, that's how I know that these are not logical realities, that Nietzsche is right, is because we don't feel good, right? So you can do the math problem and say it proves that this, I should feel fine. And the culture is saying I should feel fine. And I have all the images and the stuff around me of a healthy life. I have all the symptoms of being happy. But guess what? You don't. Okay. And that voice that says you're not is real. And the first step in getting back in touch with this stuff is admitting that it is real, even though you can't see it and touch it and taste it and
可能会说他们做CBT，他们实际上不再做CBT了。我有一个CBT治疗师，他说，把你的恐惧变成焦虑。或者不，对不起。他说，把你的恐惧和焦虑变成动力和兴奋，因为那是同样的能量。这只取决于你如何与那种能量互动，以及你对自己说了什么。这是同样的
sort of re-achieving balance between these things. So, you know, like what does that kind of therapy look like? Again, I'm not making a new model of therapy um but this could like lead us to understand inner wisdom and and compassion and the stuff that i talk about all the time instead of driving trying to just strive to perfectly understand and control and so you know patients could start to understand like how to embrace the uncertainty of life um and and that being a good thing or an inevitable thing a thing that maybe makes us terrified but also motivates us um i had a cbt therapist which a lot of cbt therapists are great therapists even though i don't like cognitive therapy if you code a lot of cbt therapists they've just done it long enough that they
情绪。我并不害怕。我很兴奋，因为我想改变。我不知道我会如何改变，或者我是否能改变，但以那种方式感受它对我的大脑好多了。所以因为治疗师，这很难，因为我们必须承认我们在这种不确定性中漂泊，这些系统正在失败，我们不知道如何修复。而且你，你不想冒犯病人的政治观点，或者你不想让他们更沮丧。好吧，你知道，他们无论如何都知道这一点，你对自己有多少尊重，你对你的病人有多少尊重？我的意思是，谁，哦，好吧，就像每当我听到治疗师说，哦，他们只是还没准备好听到更大的声音。我不得不听她继续讲这种叙事，
may say they do cbt they're not really doing CBT anymore. I had a CBT therapist and he said, turn your fear into anxiety. Or no, I'm sorry. He said, turn your like fear and anxiety into motivation and excitement because it's the same energy. It just matters how you interact with that energy and what you're telling yourself about it. It's the same
但她只是还没准备好知道。你不尊重这个人。我过去常看青少年，我仍然以对待成年人的尊重对待他们。你以为你是谁？你可能只是还没准备好和他们进行那次谈话。我根本不理解那种治疗。我作为治疗师和你在一起。我认为好的治疗师应该这样。我不是在评判你，分析你，并决定，你知道，你什么时候成熟
emotion. I wasn't afraid. I was excited because I wanted to change. And I didn't know how I would, or if I could, but feeling it that way was so much better for my brain. And so because therapists, this is hard because we have to admit that we're adrift in this uncertainty and that these systems are failing that we don't know how to fix. And you're, you don't want to offend the patient's politics or you don't want to make them more depressed. Well, you know, they know this anyway, how much respect do you have for yourself and how much respect do you have for your patients? I mean, who, oh, well, like whenever I hear a therapist be like, oh, they're just not ready to hear the greater. I'm having to listen to her go on about this kind of narrative,
到足以无论什么，你知道，而且猜猜怎么着？我的意思是，治疗师，你说病人什么时候准备好了？他们不是治疗师，关系在四年内破裂了。然后他们只是说，哦，他们还没准备好去那里或者什么。你知道，就像那些说病人没准备好的治疗师，就像我从来没见过他们让病人准备好。你知道，作为一个和很多治疗师谈了很长时间，并且在那个世界里待了很长时间的人，也和很多做我不做的治疗的治疗师谈过。所以，你知道，我们必须对病人诚实。但在这样做时，我们冒着看起来很愚蠢的风险。我们冒着看起来不合格的风险，因为，哦，我不
but she's just not ready yet to know. You don't respect this person. I used to see teenagers, and I still treated them with the respect that I would give an adult. Who do you think you are? You're maybe just not ready to have that conversation with them. I just don't get that kind of therapy at all. I'm there with you as a therapist. I think good therapists should be. I'm not like judging you and analyzing you and deciding, you know, when you're mature
知道该告诉你什么。所以这会结束。所以我猜我不够好。你知道，我们冒着看起来疯狂的风险。如果你有那些不安全感，处理它们，然后去接受治疗，对吧？就像如果你是治疗师，处理那些不安全感，因为你不愚蠢，你不不合格，你也不疯狂，但是的，有人可能会认为你是，那对你有什么影响？你知道，我们作为治疗师也不知道怎么做这个。我们不能假装，我们也不知道怎么做，但我们必须发展，我的意思是，也许这是一种后世俗信仰或什么，但我们必须发展，我的意思是，也许这是一种后世俗信仰或什么，但我们必须发展一种直觉来知道我们走哪个方向，即使我们并不真正
enough to whatever, you know, and guess what? I mean, the therapist, you say that when is the patient ready? They aren't the therapist, the relationship falls apart in four years. And then they just say, oh, they weren't ready to go there or whatever. You know, like the therapists who say the patient's not ready, like I never see them get the patient ready. You know, as somebody who has talked to a lot of therapists for a long time and been in that world for a long time, and also talked to a lot of therapists who do kinds of therapy I don't do. So, you know, we have to be honest with patients. But in doing that, we run the risk of seeming stupid. We run the risk of seeing unqualified because, oh, I don't
知道这怎么结束或走哪个方向。我们必须在一种文化中做所有这些，这种文化长期以来只给了我们一堆破碎的意象和一大堆不确定性。这就是它所做的。所以对于后现代自我，你知道，那怎么适合一个世界？我们只是，我们不能倒带时钟。你知道，YouTube视频里有人提出了一个论点，他们说，哦，你知道，我们有所有这些觉醒文化或这种腐败和这种坏事。我们只需要回去成为罗马帝国。就像你到底怎么回去成为罗马帝国？就像我从来没听过那些人中的任何一个，除了他们只是不喜欢一群人，
know what to tell you. So this will end. So I guess I'm not good enough. You know, we run the risk of seeming crazy. If you have those insecurities, deal with them and then go into therapy, right? Like deal with those insecurities if you're a therapist, because you're not stupid, you're not unqualified and you're not crazy, but yeah, somebody may think you are, what does that do to you? You know, we don't know how to do this as therapists either. We can't pretend to, and we don't know how, but we have to develop the, I mean, maybe it's a post-secular faith or something, but we have to develop the, I mean, maybe it's a post-secular faith or something, but we have to develop an intuition to know which direction that we go in, even if we don't really
有任何想法，你怎么让一个拥有数十亿人的世界忘记过去一千年发生的事情。或者500年，或者你想回溯多远。然后只是说，记住，那些文化事物都不再是一个选项了。你能就那样忘记吗？那太狂野了。你可以。就像，我们处于后后现代主义中。嗯，这就是我们所在的地方，我们被这些我们假装理解的力量所生活，就像奥登（Auden）所说的。而且，你知道，这些正在通过我们的这种原型生活的古老潮流，正在不断地破坏你试图制造的任何一种
know how this ends or which direction to go. And we must do like all of this in a culture that has given us nothing but a heap of broken images and a whole mess ton of uncertainty for a long time. That's what it's done. And so for the postmodern self, you know, how does that fit into a world? We just, we can't rewind the clock. You know, the YouTube video where somebody makes an argument and they're like, oh, you know, we have all this woke culture or this corruption and this bad thing. We just need to go back and be the Roman empire. Like how the hell are you going to go back and be the Roman empire? Like I've never heard a single one of those people, other than they just don't like a group of people,
理性的叙事或个人身份，这可能是可怕的，或者它可能是令人兴奋的，这是同样的能量，然而这些不是应该被掌握的障碍，你知道，它们是，我不会把这个放在治疗计划上。它们是这种原始材料，是你可以飞行的创造性热风。而现在也许你有时必须冲浪。你知道，治疗变成了这种呈现潜能和代谢事物的艺术。如果你想用炼金术的语言，荣格的方式，谈论炼金术，
have any kind of idea how you make a world full of billions of people forget that the last thousand years happened. Or 500, or however far you want to go back. And then just say, remember, none of those cultural things are an option anymore. Could you just kind of forget that? That's wild. You can. Like, we are in post post-modernism. Um, that's where we are and we are lived by these forces that we pretend to understand, like Auden says. And, you know, these archaic currents that are coming through us of this archetypal life are perpetually destabilizing any kind of
那种语言也有效。但在这个后世俗、后经验的世界里，心理治疗的这个目标，当我们意识到科学的局限性，我们意识到神话本身的局限性，或者魔法，相信魔法，无论什么，我们意识到神话本身的局限性，或者魔法，相信魔法，你知道，无论什么，我们意识到那东西的局限性，你知道，就像，它不能追求这种绝对真理。不仅仅是因为尼采会取笑你，而是它必须帮助病人发展这种能力
rational narrative or personal identity that you try and make which can be terrifying or it can be exciting it's the same energy and yet these are not obstacles that should just be mastered you know they're i wouldn't put this on the treatment plant. They're this raw material of their creative thermals of wind that you can fly on. And now maybe you have to surf on sometimes. You know, therapy becomes this art of presencing the interplay of potentiality and metabolizing things. And if you want to go in an alchemical language, a Jungian way, and talk about alchemy,
通过拥抱一种更谦逊、直觉的心理健康方法，以勇气、好奇心和同情心面对未知。我们必须承认我们不知道。我们必须承认不确定性。我们必须坐在不确定性中，我们可以帮助个人在一个总是会改变的世界中找到意义。因为如果你在等待环境改变，就像它并不总是改变，特别是当那个环境是文化时，你知道，嗯，但我们可以培养韧性。嗯，如果你在挠头，心想，我不知道该怎么做。我不知道怎么做。那，那很好。那很好。你在思考它。我也不知道怎么做，但我有信念，我觉得那种信念比我知道的东西更真实。
that language works too. But this goal of psychotherapy in this post-secular, post-empirical world, where we realize the limitations of science, and we realize the limitations of mythology alone, or magic, believing in magic, whatever, we realize the limitations of mythology alone, or magic, believing in magic, you know, whatever, we realize the limitations of that, you know, like, it can't go after this absolute truth. Not just because Nietzsche will make fun of you, but it has to help patients develop this capacity
这种说法也行得通。但在这样一个后世俗、后经验主义的世界里，当我们意识到科学的局限性，意识到仅靠神话或魔法——相信魔法之类的东西——的局限性时，我们意识到这些东西的局限性，你知道，它无法追求这种绝对真理。这不仅仅是因为尼采会嘲笑你，而是因为它必须帮助患者培养这种能力
to face the unknown with courage and curiosity and compassion by embracing a more humble, intuitive approach to mental health. And we have to admit that we don't know. We have to admit uncertainty. We have to sit in uncertainty and we can help individuals find meaning in a world that is always going to be in change. Because if you're waiting for the environment to change, like it doesn't always, especially when that environment is culture, you know, uh, but we can cultivate resilience. Um, and if you're scratching your head and you're like, I don't know what to do that. I don't know how to do that. That's, that's fine. That's good. You're thinking about it. I don't know how to do it either, but I have faith and I feel that faith is more real than what I know.
即通过拥抱一种更谦逊、更直觉的心理健康方法，以勇气、好奇心和同情心去面对未知。我们必须承认我们不知道。我们必须承认不确定性。我们必须安于不确定性，我们可以帮助个人在一个永远处于变化中的世界里寻找意义。因为如果你在等待环境改变，它并不总是会改变，尤其是当环境是文化的时候，你知道，呃，但我们可以培养韧性。嗯，如果你感到困惑，觉得我不知道该怎么做。我不知道该怎么做。没关系。那很好。你在思考这个问题。我也不知道该怎么做，但我有信念，我觉得信念比我所知道的更真实。
And the future has always been a simulacra, right? The future has always been a copy without original because the past is built on all these copies of inner images that people were externalizing, sometimes consciously and sometimes not. And all we can learn is to recognize these images inside ourselves and these images outside ourselves and the interplay between those how we're taking them in how we're taking them out and make a choice make it a choice instead of an unconscious process and you know our lives are always this interplay of forces that we cannot we can't prevent or defeat that but what we can do is learn to build behavior and and cultural machinery to handle the dynamics of the flow of those forges forces i don't know if anyone's seen
未来一直都是一种拟像，对吧？未来一直都是没有原件的复制品，因为过去是建立在人们外化出的所有这些内心图像的副本之上的，有时是有意识的，有时则不然。我们所能学习的，就是去识别我们内心的这些图像，以及我们外部的这些图像，还有它们之间的相互作用——我们如何吸收它们，如何输出它们——并做出选择，让它成为一种选择，而不是一个无意识的过程。你知道，我们的生活始终是这些力量的相互作用，我们无法阻止或战胜它们，但我们能做的是学会建立行为和文化机制来处理这些力量流动的动态。我不知道是否有人看过
patriot on amazon it's good but i think the book that like the his engineer boss writes is called like the the dynamics of flow or something um he's it's, it's, he's an engineer. Um, but like we, we are lived by forces that we pretend to understand, but we have to remember too, that they are lived through us. You know, we are lived through them and they are lived through us. There's an interplay that we, and we can have some awareness of that tension. Um, and that is scary because it makes us a little bit less of an individual. It makes us a little bit less of an individual. It makes us a little bit less of a monolith or this monadic thing that is going through life. But that isn't life.
亚马逊上的《爱国者》，它很不错，但我认为他那位工程师老板写的书叫《流动的动力学》之类的。嗯，他是一位工程师。但是，我们被我们假装理解的力量所驱动，但我们也必须记住，它们也通过我们而存在。你知道，我们通过它们而活，它们也通过我们而活。我们之间存在一种相互作用，我们可以对这种张力有一定的觉知。嗯，这很可怕，因为它让我们作为一个个体的色彩淡化了一些。它让我们不再那么像一个整体，或者说不再是那个独自经历生活的单子。但那并不是生活。
You have archetypes within you. There are archetypes outside of you. We can look at how these things are knocking together. But that means that you have to let go of what you are right now or this thing that's completely in control because you're not you know when i was in psychotherapy i remembered that there were all these drowning and swimming metaphors in school too and like that you know just there's a ton of like well you got to learn to swim sometimes the backstroke whatever and you know you're trying to do the if you're floating on your back and the or you know like yeah that that protective part it was helping you out and it was a stick that kept you float in the river.
你的内心有原型，你的外部也有原型。我们可以观察这些事物是如何碰撞的。但这意味着你必须放下你现在的样子，或者放下那个试图完全掌控一切的自我，因为你做不到。你知道，当我在接受心理治疗时，我记得学校里也有很多关于溺水和游泳的隐喻，比如你得学会游泳，有时是仰泳，无论什么姿势。你知道，如果你试图仰泳，或者说，那个保护性的部分曾经在帮助你，它就像一根让你在河里漂浮的木棍。
But now the stick is about to go over the waterfall. And if you can't let it go and swim to the shore, if you keep holding on to the protective part, you know, all of that stuff, but maybe the sea is just too rough right now to teach patients to swim like that has changed. And we can't do that. And we need to teach patients how to sail both. You know, Freud taking apart the whole engine and trying to teach the patient how to be a speedboat or fix the speedboat, not going to happen. The sea is too rough to swim. But we can teach them to be in conversation with these forces
但现在这根木棍即将随水流冲下瀑布。如果你不能放手并游向岸边，如果你一直紧紧抓住那个保护性的部分，你知道，所有那些东西……但也许现在海面太汹涌了，无法教病人那样游泳，情况已经变了。我们做不到那样。我们需要教病人如何驾驶帆船。你知道，弗洛伊德拆解了整个引擎，试图教病人如何成为快艇或修理快艇，这行不通。海面太汹涌，无法游泳。但我们可以教他们与这些力量进行对话，
in a way that is sustainable, like through sailing. And maybe we can build a culture that can learn to, like, sail and cruise ships again. You know, um, maybe we can be in conversation with the storm, um, because it's not going to go away. And if it does, it's not going to go away because of magic, because of anything we did. And it's not going to go away because of science. We are in a storm, and I think that instead of trying to swim, we need to remember to breathe, and we need to remember how to use the wind. Thank you. Продолжение следует... There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以一种可持续的方式，比如通过航行。也许我们可以建立一种文化，学会再次航行和驾驶游轮。你知道，也许我们可以与风暴进行对话，因为它不会消失。即使它消失了，也不是因为魔法，也不是因为我们做了什么。它也不会因为科学而消失。我们正处于风暴之中，我认为与其试图游泳，我们不如记住呼吸，记住如何利用风。谢谢。未完待续……本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。